make that no cantor anthony simon's in
blazers go five out wide dame rolls in
the difficult lay-in
tough the play before he gets the switch
with marketing who's fouling him
the entire way to the basket but he
powers through it all
and gets the ball chicago with their
highest scoring quarter of the game here
in the fourth quarter so far
dang gets it with white checking dame
deep look from outside there's the three
entire time and that makes that possible
to get the jump ball
dame with 41 gary tran jr to jump
against a two-time slam dunk champion
lasers get the tip five seconds left
covington trying to get it to dame he
puts it on the floor step back three
from dame
[Music]
damien lillard game
winner in chicago back to back threes
to break the heart of the bulls
wow
it's that time
dame oh scramble
balls loose for a second
dame creating space picking on market
and yet again
both hands in the air
celebration play was under review but
all you will see
is the jubilation of the trailblazers
and
unbelievable finish from chicago
damien lillard back to back threes
blazers
trailed by five